edouard husson merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors quelle
information principale vous retenez des
mots du président français mais elle
même macron à l'issue de ces deux heures
de rencontre avec la chancelière angela
merkel écoutez je ris de veau je risque
de vous décevoir mais je pense qu'il ya
pas grand chose qu'est-ce qu'on a qu'est
ce qu'on vient d'entendre on vient
d'entendre rappelé le plan de relance
mais on savait qu'il a il existe mais il
n'a toujours pas été votée par parlement
européen on sait qu'il ya toujours une
bataille très dure en police pour de la
part des pays appelés les frigos pour
essayer de directives mans d'obtenir
encore des avantages on a entendu une
façon diplomatique de montrer des
différences sur sur la turquie par
exemple bon globalement si vous voulez
moi ce qui me frappe dans cette façon
des manuels mac ont présenté les choses
c'est que il y a une espèce
d'incantations de la coopération
franco-allemande des vocations du passé
mais les grandes décisions elles sont
prises elles sont prises sans ça c'est à
dire que si vous voulez le l'accord dit
historique de plan de relance n'a pu
marcher que parce que la france a
accepté de recevoir enfin de donner 70
milliards de plus que ce qu'elle recevra
je veux bien mais si tout accord
européen doit se faire avec un sacrifice
des intérêts français
je pense que la population française il
sera de plus en plus opposées avec le
temps les grandes puissances y compris
l'allemagne et les tous les membres de
l'union européenne ont bien compris et
les petits pays aussi les frigos ou bien
compte que l'union européenne est un
cadre dentelle
chacun défend ses intérêts doit bien les
prendre je pense qu'il n'ya qu emmanuel
macron qui sacrifient à la mystique
européenne avec des résultats qui sont
qui sont sur le papier impressionnant
mais qui se font aux dépens des intérêts
français
mais edouard ils sont finalement qu'à
vous
te veut révéler le couple franco
allemand avec ce rendez vous au coeur de
l'été au fort de brégançon la résidence
estivale du président de la république
oui messi ou moi c'est de la coop en
gala merkel s'y prête parce que c'est
plus confortable pour elle de ne pas
avoir des négociations dures avec la
partie française et du côté français
emmanuel macron entretient le mythe
d'une conduite et franco-allemande
ailleurs il a commencé sa conférence de
presse en faisant référence au passé il
ya 35 ans helmut kohl et françois
mitterrand
mais c'était une autre époque c'était
une époque où les français se battait
plus dans l'est dans les négociations
européennes
aujourd'hui notre intérêt il est d'être
plus solidaires avec l'espagne d'être
plus solidaires avec l'italie il est
comme meilleur il faut le dire le
président français l'a fait de défendre
la grèce et les intérêts de la grèce en
méditerranée mais on voit bien que y'a
si vous voulez une grande illusion
française dont emmanuel macron est
éminemment porter c'est l'idée selon
laquelle autres membres de l'union
européenne voudrait d'une europe
puissance mais ils n'en n'ont pas voulu
y à il ya 20 ou 30 ans ils en veulent
encore moins maintenant l'europe c'est
l'occasion de faire de bonnes affaires
de défendre des intérêts économiques de
faciliter des échanges commerciaux et
france a une politique étrangère qui se
respecte d'ailleurs qui pourrait être
plus plus clair quelquefois mais en
l'occurrence si je trouve bon que la
france s'est défendu les intérêts de la
grèce que ne nous laissions pas faire
par la turquie je pense pas qu'on ait
besoin d'enrobé tout ça de rhétorique
européenne
surtout qu'on sait très bien que people
est dans une attitude très différente
vis-à-vis de la turquie parce que elle
est mise
elle est doublement mis sous pression
par ailleurs de gamme d'une part parce
que ils menacent régulièrement
enfin il fait un chantage à la la
reprise de de l'immigration vers
l'allemagne et d'autre part parce que
elle a des minorités turques extrêmement
importante sur le sur le territoire
allemand
donc je sais voilà ce que je pense je ne
dis pas qu'il n'ya pas de politique
française et on l'a vu sur dans le cas
de la turquie et la grèce et de la
turquie en méditerranée
voit aussi dans les forfaits pour
essayer de remettre de l'ordre en libye
en revanche je ne vois pas pourquoi on
devrait l'habiller en permanence
derrière cette rhétorique européiste et
franco allemande
d'ailleurs le président françois on a
entendu à parler d' approche différente
notamment sur le sujet de la turquie que
vous venez d'évoquer mais finalement
pour des fins convergentes
comment vous comprenez cette phrase on
bat ces deux là c'est de la langue de
bois diplomatique
c'est une façon de dire que depuis cette
crise qui dure depuis plusieurs semaines
l attitude fait de la france qui pense
il y à un chantage à turquie et qui
pense que il faut défendre les intérêts
grecs et les intérêts de chypre et il ya
une attitude d'apaisement depuis ce
meurtre de madame merkel qui ne
souhaitent pas un bras de fer avec
erdogan erdogan essaye de jouer de ça
alors simplement le contexte est sans
doute moins favorable et puis tu et vous
voulez en méditerranée rue il ya c'est à
pétrolier très fort mais si c'était
d'ailleurs sur cette zone parce qu'il
dit beaucoup de choses
rappelez vous il ya dix ans ou même en
il ya cinq ans on parlait de la dette
grecque si la france et l'allemagne à
l'époque s'étaient entendus pour que la
grèce puisse exploiter ces hydrocarbures
le problème de la delà de la dette
grecque était été résolus simplement
pour ça il fallait une une position
franco allemand beaucoup plus forte
il fallait affronter d'autres pays
producteurs et rool défendre les
intérêts de la grèce au sein de l'union
européenne ça n'a pas été fait pourquoi
parce que l'allemagne ça ne
l'intéressait pas d'entrer dans un bras
de fer géopolitique avec les pays
producteurs de pétrole et et que par
ailleurs l'allemagne ne souhaite pas
avoir une politique de puissance pour l
union européenne c c'est la garantie de
de sa prospérité économique et doit se
sont renvoyés avec l'exemple de la grèce
on est sur on est sur le coeur du sujet
alors edouard husson autres sujets
abordés c'est la situation en
biélorussie
annuel maquereau au lendemain du sommet
extraordinaire des 27 ils n'ont pas
reconnu on le rappelle l'élection en
biélorussie emmanuel macron a proposé
une médiation de l'union européenne en
biélorussie en incluant l la russie oui
écoutez je pense que on est sur un autre
à notre exemple où la france a une
politique propre
c'est vrai que en tout cas pas pour à
l'allemagne la france a tendu la main à
la russie
malgré le blocus malgré l'hostilité
américaine
alala la russie malgré le contexte
géopolitique et c'est vrai qu emmanuel
macron a voulu entendre une voix
originale derniers mois là on veut tel
vraiment je pense que l'allemagne
souhaiterait rester sur une stratégie
qui ressemblerait à l'attitude vis-à-vis
de l'ukraine était depuis la crise de
crime et emmanuel macron lui voudrait
impliquer la russie d'ailleurs par
réalisme
il sait que aucune crise biélorusse ou
ukrainiennes ne peut se résoudre sans la
russie
donc c'est là aussi le filon de la
politique française
mais là encore pourquoi leurs robes et
derrière la rhétorique européenne la
france reste une puissance et elle peut
jouer un rôle elle peut peser
elle peut dialoguer avec la russie elle
peut mettre des gens autour de la table
françois hollande l'avait l'avait bien
fait au moment de dollar de la crise
craignait nez il avait obtenu les actes
de minsk après il les avait défendus
mais la france a de l'influencé
si vous voulez pourquoi mettre sa
toujours sous le drapeau de l'union
européenne est ce que la france nous
couple franco-allemand aujourd'hui c'est
encore la locomotive de l'europe selon
vous non je ne prends pas du tout je
pense qu'on a on a complètement changé
si vous voulez là vous avez eue
vous avez eu en fait deux changements
majeurs ces dernières années les le
premier ça a été la l'élargissement de
l'union européenne
l'entrée des pays d'europe centrale et
orientale et dans ce dans ce contexte là
les règles de la négociation européenne
ont complètement changé et d'ailleurs
vous voyez comment fait l'allemagne
l'allemagne se constitue sur chaque vote
une clientèle à une coalition qui lui
permet d'imposer ses intérêts la france
ne fait jamais la même chose ou rarement
et c'est dommage parce que c'est comme
ça c'est du marchand d'art mais c'est
comme ça que ça se fasse dans dans dans
l'union européenne
le deuxième gros changement est là la
france devrait essayer de l'utiliser à
son profit mais elle ne le fait pas
c'est le départ de la grande bretagne
c'est le fait que la grande bretagne ne
sera plus là pour servir d'un arbitre
entre la france et l'allemagne et pour
trouver pour trouver des positions qui
permettent de fait de faire voter
ensemble les deux pays et donc ça va
changer les choses
on va rentrer dans une logique qui sera
beaucoup plus une logique d'affrontement
entre la france et l'allemagne au sein
de au sein de l'union européenne chacune
ayant à se constituer une coalition
alors entendons-nous affrontement
diplomatique mais je pense que tant que
le président français n'aura pas compris
que son défi c'est de créer des
alliances et qu' il ne peut pas avoir
les yeux simplement tournés vers berlin
en 10 ans comme il l'a fait dans sa
conférence de presse qu une fois que la
france et l'allemagne ont lancé quelque
chose s'est ouvert aux autres pays
européens c'est très méprisant vis-à-vis
des autres pays européens
est-ce qu'on fait que l'italie l'espagne
pense que toute politique avec
l'allemagne doit passer par paris ont
peu de politiques avec avec paris assez
par berlin ils attendent que l'allemagne
la france leur donne effectivement des
désavantages dans les politiques qui
vont être mises en oeuvre
ça s'appelle la négociation et je pense
qu'aussi emmanuel macron fait une autre
erreur
il est extrêmement méprisant vis-à-vis
des des pays considérés comme petit mais
vu le système de vote
il n'y a pas de petits pays en europe on
a toujours besoin d'un petit pays pour
galerie un vote et je crois qu'il faut
un profond changement de la mentalité
française et de la façon de négocier au
sein des institutions européennes merci
merci beaucoup edouard husson d'avoir
répondu à nos questions après la
conférence de presse et la prise de
parole des manuels macron suite à la
rencontre franco-allemande au fort de
brégançon merci edouard husson je
rappelle que vous êtes historien
professeur à l'université de
cergy-pontoise hauteur de paris berlin
la survie de l'europe aux éditions
gallimard